i said no i said no don't slowly go go
up my leg like that what was that noise
hello and welcome to random encounter I
have hijacked a random encounter because
obviously I'm not Daniel Dwyer I'm Eric
today that's max hulbert um today we're
gonna play some mount your friends so
let's go into it oh yeah that's right
and it's like the Smurfs guy this pretty
much explains the entirety of the game a
lot of gyration a lot of physics
although a lot of dong physics here
alright let's jump in a1v alright let's
do it oh look at that guy's gotta Monica
hey is that that's a sweet goat right
there alright i climb back out florencio
protiv oast do we know what flag that is
what country do you hail from get onto
the goat oh man you're going backward
it's all about controlling your moment
so fair the first person gets the whole
time oh man you look at your attention
so only mean dog physics look at that
here we go a solid first game all right
guy Jago yeah uh who looks like his eye
level is not quite at the same look oh
I'll pin it on the ass rub that us yeah
there you go right on the jail tip just
the tip all right no no no no we're not
done yet so all you need to do is just
barely pass the top of the last oh so my
first guy doesn't have a timer either oh
we really goes good my guy looks like
Mike crawler I know Oh where's the roof
the roof oh yeah look at that oh right
sorry is that your dog right there oh
sorry was that just your tip or was it
to let the tip I'm sorry in his face he
does not like that well you know he's
making a no face of anything oh my foots
on my foots on my other guys done
did you really grabbing dong a man i
asserted its whatever it takes to get to
the top i don't i don't have look oh I'm
so sorry so sorry oh I got you I got my
foot on it to what do you hear what do
you think like that I feel like I could
get more out of this yeah hey should we
just like that oh look just wave your
hands in the air my guys protecting his
dong see he did the full like no you
can't see it cuz you have it I'm gonna
angle it so it's so dirty Oh miss me big
lips we call him big lips jimenez big
lips oliva's for obvious reasons you
mean this this this manner oh [ __ ] oh oh
good there's no time outside though
because all the way did I was Charlie I
was trying to press Start but I fat
finger did we're gonna full full release
okay full release on to the other side
Oh stone to the pit sound a little bit
stop building so far over it's such a
pain in the ass to cross sideways oh
yeah how're your little like head damn
flowers you're so cute and this is Mike
it's all balanced truck see what i did
was attached just one limb and no oh
that shooting him from shooting the gap
and do your little cartwheel trick like
that wow he just bolted off my guy dude
dude you're all over this game now you
could go pro you could go pro mount your
friends get off my dog but get your foot
off my dog man
you're an [ __ ] I see what you're
doing you're dancing now Wow shots fired
by yeah 28 I don't have experience if
anything I think max obviously has
experienced mounting his friends cuz he
has the ability to cartwheel from one
side to the other look at your arm it
wasn't even attached to your elbow it
like clipped my guy who you are you
gonna do the oh my god I got it I wish
you fell into the pit this isn't we're
doing pretty well this one ok now oh you
got six seconds though come on release
all the way down I I got flustered and I
I pressed the wrong button I was like
I'm gonna make it I mean I pressed why
instead and my guy did a little cart
wheel down all the way down oh I didn't
mean to attach all those oh yeah you did
oh man no no the physics I die I want to
stop staring I just can't oh man oh look
at that a little hop in the air a little
just like wood oh you're gonna stay on
your side oh no I I applaud your
boldness in in your attempt to to hop
from one side to the other had you have
landed it I think I would have just
backed out and admitted defeat I was X
Games material that was that was X Games
meets mount your friends oh oh come on
get your dog oh sorry was it was it in
the oh right there good another good
sorry sorry sorry sorry my apologies sir
goat
what yeah right down right there get it
right and we saw asked first hey man
you're my friend you're my friend i can
mount you yep right on the right off the
tip yep nothing new challenges new
challenge yeah you're gonna have to
reach you got to reach around for that
you're gonna have to do the reach around
from that I'll get out of here get out
of here you're not allowed i said no i
said no don't slowly go go up my leg
like that I said no Zach oh you're a
monster Zakk your monster it's like a
gentle stroke stroke in the leg oh you
can't even get to mine I blocked mine
off with my hand you see my god its
protection its protection I know what's
going on here don't like a do it though
oh yeah don't leave it exposed I'm
coming for it don't leave it exposed
don't leave it x 0 it's okay it might
protrude it might protrude well look at
that guy's name gusty I don't even know
how to say it zangi mccune life is good
this is oh you get off local / little
Adam and Eve action little Adam and Eve
look it's Ben's just like everything up
I think I'm dead I think I'm dead max oh
yeah you are you got it you got two more
guys to go at least I didn't get a good
start on you guys what a jump come on
okay let go at least let go damn it it's
like three two one right now just gonna
take on you gotta release and flip over
oh you suck you sure this is sabotage
saboteur that's a look of somebody you
got his dong grab it's not right
for it like that yeah exactly oh my
goodness i was getting epic struggle to
get to the top can he make it I think
he's gonna lose oh no oh get out of my
armpit get out of my armpit
always struggling oh he's he's getting
greedy he's getting real greedy what an
[ __ ] is it will the hero prevail
you're saying
no clearly
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm panting okay we'll play
max you dominated me today I dominating
in the dong mount eagle on it look look
the guys aren't in between stay low my
head is higher than him so you know
anyways thank you guys for tuning in of
course tomorrow there is megabit at 11
and later today we have infamous
infamous second son two o'clock so back
for that that's now playing we're gonna
have a Deb in but see you guys then and
we'll get up highlights of mount your
friends soon thanks max thanks everyone
who thanks for watching do you guys